here in this country president biden met
virtually with g7 leaders as part of
renewed efforts to isolate russia by
cutting off moscow's cash flow from oil
exports nasa cordes is at the white
house nancy good morning we also saw
first lady joe biden visiting ukraine
over the weekend for mother's day good
morning nate that's right the white
house tells reporters that the first
lady has wanted to go to ukraine since
march and of course we know that her
president has expressed his desire to
visit as well but in the end she was the
one who got there first in a trip that
came together just a few days ago
first lady jill biden arrived in a
ukrainian border town sunday bearing
flowers for the country's first lady
alina zelenska zelenska has not been
seen in public since the start of the
russian invasion her location and her
children's kept secret during the war i
wanted to come on
mother's day i thought it was important
to show the ukrainian people
that this war has to stop coaching
we all feel your support and we all feel
the leadership of the u.s president
her husband ukrainian president
zielinski spoke with some g7 leaders on
sunday including president biden who
joined the call from wilmington delaware
the group announced that all seven
countries will either phase out or
totally ban imports of russian oil in an
effort to target one of russia's biggest
sources of income
many european countries are dependent on
russian oil and until yesterday only the
u.s had banned it separately the u.s
also unleashed a new round of sanctions
on russia's biggest state television
networks barred americans from
consulting on business with anyone in
russia and set a host of new visa
restrictions for russian elites
ukraine's ambassador to the u.s welcomed
the moves we count on all of our friends
and allies to help us with everything so
we can stop russia while it's still in
ukraine
as russia was celebrating its victory
day the u.s was sending diplomats back
to the u.s embassy in kiev for the first
time now this was just a temporary visit
but the state department is hoping to
reopen the embassy fully sometime in the
coming weeks tarika
nancy cordes force at the white house
thank you